a group of unemployed Nevadans share
their frustrations with the unemployment
filing system they could be seen outside
the grant Sawyer building that's where
we find Joe Moller with more on the
demonstration from earlier Joe well for
months we've been hearing from people
were unable to get their unemployment
benefits and the ones who came out here
today say they are fed up they want to
send a clear message to the governor and
to the director of dieter
they all came out here to explain why
exactly they're not getting their money
and they're upset about it they call and
cannot get through to any sort of person
to get any sort of answer one woman
tells me their online portal shows no
issues with their claim but they still
haven't received money and don't know
why they are frustrated and worried if
something does not happen soon thank God
I'm on Section eight
these other people that might not be I
don't know how they're doing it I don't
know I you know pretty soon them off to
pitch a tent if I can't pay my little
bit of money that I do pay and we just
suck it up and hoping looking at our
photos looking on our computers hoping
that we're getting a payday looking at
our checking accounts those who ask the
right deposit things like that they're
nothing
[Music]
just about every day we talk to people
who have not got paid many since March
and the concern is what they will do
next month when they can't pay their
bills now that virtual press conference
happens every single Friday for the past
few weeks now and the director dorita
director of dieter holds us virtually
and you're supposed to send questions
ahead of time and the answer the
questions that they once now back to the
the question regarding those pending
claims that have been sent in and the
director said that they are just more
complex and take time the people out
here today say that's not really a fair
answer and they still want more answers
regarding it they say these protests
will continue until issues are resolved
reporting live at the Grand Sawyer
building I'm Jim Bohlen I'll send it
back to you